this is bryan dolby at the ftth council
event in europe where i have an
interview with the real wow factor I'm
talking to Anders Christensen who is the
CEO of the company Wow and as you just
took part in the CEO panel and tell us
about some of the main points you were
making well first of all Brian that's
right we were called Wow and that's
because the experience we want to give
our customers is an experience of wow so
anyways one of the key important
messages that my address was about us
delivering what we call a speed warranty
so we actually deliver the internet
speed that we market and that's quite
unusual because it is so that there is
really no regulation requiring Internet
service providers to deliver the speed
day market so it is such that if you
compare it to milk you are actually
allowed to sell a liter of our car litre
of milk and only deliver half a liter we
don't think that's ok so we guarantee
our customers that with us they get the
speed that they've been marketed great
news how did you manage to achieve that
well we have an FTTH network so actually
delivering the speed that we market is
easy on and not easy but it's possible
on an FTTH network now I think also as
an operator you've even managed to
improve profitability at the same time
yeah that's right so what we've done is
we entered the market at a price point
or an our pool level which was not the
lowest of the market but what we did do
was to give customers excellent price
value so more megabits per euro and so
so the prices have actually been
competitive but not rock bottom low in
terms of alpha and then we've combined
it with getting economies of scale by
merging three smaller service providers
into one large national service provider
so we have a national service provider
we have one brand and we have local
sales so that's kind of the reason for
improving
debility great well thanks for talking
to as Anders okay thank you
you